عن حزمه المساعدات الجديده لاوكرانيا تحدث
عن مضاعفه مدى صواريخ هايمرس التي تم
تزويده اوكرانيا بها لكنه لم يتحدث عن
صواريخ بعيده المدى يمكن ان تصل الى عمق
الاراضي الروسيه خلافا لكل التوقعات التي
صارت خلال الايام الماضيه واثارت ردود فعل
واسعه في روسيا الى اي مدى ستغير الصفقه
الجديده من مجريات الحرب وكيف ستكون
امكانياتكيف الصاروخيه في ضوء المساعدات
الجديده مقارنه بامكانياتها الحاليه هذا
ما نناقشه مع ضيفنا من بيروت الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا
اهلا بك سياده العميد اذا واضح ان الغضب
الروسي متمثلا في تصريحات
امدد فقد وصل اوجه هو يهدد باحراق كل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تحت
الاوكرانيا كيف
نقرا هذا التهديد الجديد هل فيه شيء مختلف
هذه المره
ليلى الواقع مختلف في اوكرانيا اليوم
الفريقان يتحضران لمرحله ما بعد الشتاء او
لهجوم ما بعد الشتاء التعزيزات الامريكيه
قد تضرب المخططات الروسيه وبالتالي يجب ان
نعترف ان تقريبا كل اوكرانيا مدمره اذا لم
نستثنينا فقط المنطقه الغربيه لذيذ وغيرها
وقد تكون هيدي احدى المناطق التي قد
تستهدف في المرحله القادمه خاصه لانها
الممر اللوجستي يعني الحديث عن النووي ليس
المره الاولى هو في العقيده الروسيه
النوويه يقول اذا تعرضت الاراضي
لخطر داهم على المحيط المباشر يمكن الذهاب
الى ما يسمى التصعيد لخفض التصعيد يعني
استعمال النووي وبعدها الحديث عن خفض
التسعيد فقط لضرب مخطط العدو الاخر اليوم
اربع اقاليم اساسيه دمر الرئيس بوتين
تعتبر اراضي روسيه ومن المنطلق العسكري
الخاص بروسيا تعتبر اراضي روسيه ومن هنا
التهديد الكبير طيب واضح ان الحديث عن
الصواريخ تحديدا صواريخ هايمرس هو ماساء
موجه الغضب الجديده من الجانب الروسي
لا يتحدث عن الوصول الى عمق الاراضي
الروسيه يتحدث عن زياده مدى هذه الصواريخ
ما الذي تخشاه موسكو تحديدا
ليلى الهايمرز يطال داخل الاراضي الروسيه
يعني اذا اخذنا بطاريه هايمرس من خركاف هي
تضرب الاراضي الروسيه لان العمق 80 كيلو
متر اليوم نفس الهايمرز مع تعديل بسيط
يعطى تعطى اوكرانيا ما يسمى بالجراوند
سمول كاليبر بومب يعني نفس الصاروخ مسافته
اكثر من الهايمرز دبل يعني 150 كم مع سعر
مخفض وهذا الامر اذا زاد مدى هذه الصواريخ
بعد ان تاقلمت روسيه مع الهايمرز القديم
قد يمكن ضرب حدود
القرم الشماليه وبالتالي منع اللوجستيه او
حتى ضرب عمق التجهيزات والتحضيرات
والقياده والسيطره لجيش روسيا الذي يعد
نفسه لهذه الحرب من هنا قد يعني تتخربط
كما يقال بالعميه المخططات
روسيه الخربطه هذه التي اشرت اليها ما
الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه خلال الايام الماضيه
وممن من الذي سيبدا ربما بزياده المستوى
التحدي هنا
الفريقان ليس جاهزين ليلى للروسي جاهز ولا
الاوكراني جاهز بانتظار الدبابات تدريب
لوجستيه ادخالها في المنظومه ولا حتى
القوات الروسيه ما يجري اليوم في الشرق هو
تحقيق اهداف
ونجاحات محدوده تحضيرا للمرحله القادمه
وبالتالي منع منع في الجبهه الجنوبيه خاصه
في زفروديا ان يكون هناك احتمال لهجوم
اوكرانيا لضرب الجسر البري الذي يصل القرم
بالشرق او بالدومباس وهذا هو الخطر
الحقيقي على القوات الروسيه